manifestation sous tension à rome ce
lundi plus d'une centaines de
restaurateurs et d'entrepreneurs se sont
rassemblés dans la capitale italienne en
colère ils réclament la réouverture des
restaurants ou encore des salles de
sport initiée par le mouvement et aux
approches ce rassemblement non autorisé
un objectif clair obtenir une
réouverture d'ici le 20 avril prochain
ils ont peur de la rage du peuple mais
les gens ne sont pas en colère sans
raison c'est un gros problème
il y a des raisons profondes l'état et
une dette envers moi aucune aide ne
vient je ne sais pas comment joindre les
deux bouts
nous sommes sur place parce que nous
avons le droit de manifester et de faire
grève et trouver autant de camions de
police parce que je dois faire grève
c'est un état autoritaire
peut-être que c'est bien pour bruxelles
mais pas pour nous nous sommes des
travailleurs nous ne sommes pas des
criminels des restrictions maintenu au
moins jusqu'à la fin du mois d'avril
selon mario draghi
le premier ministre italien conditionne
la réouverture des restaurants à une
baisse des cas de kobe 19 mai table
aussi sur son programme vaccinal
jeudi dernier le chef du gouvernement a
rappelé à l'ordre la population en
insistant sur l'importance de vacciner
les personnes de plus de 60 ans une
stratégie par groupe d'âge qui fait
débat au sein de la sphère politique
italienne la campanie a été l'une des
régions les plus rigoureuses d'italie
mais la rigueur est une chose la
stupidité en est une autre
je viens de m'entretenir avec le
commissaire philippe l'eau à qui j'ai
dit qu'une fois que les plus de 80 ans
et les personnes fragiles auront été
traitées nous n'avons pas l'intention de
procéder par groupes d'âge
nous consacrerons la structure publique
à la prise en charge des personnes
fragiles et âgés mais nous travaillerons
également sur les secteurs économiques
car si nous décidons d'avancer
uniquement par groupes d'âge lorsque
nous aurons terminé les groupes d'âge
l'économie italienne sera morte afin de
relancer cette économie à bout de
souffle
une nouvelle manifestation est prévue
dans la capitale italienne ce mardi
cette fois-ci autorisée par les
autorités des restaurateurs seront reçus
par le gouvernement
pour tenter de sortir de cette impasse